he has made quite a career for himself
as in an opinion a teraz in an NFL
analyst on ESPN Damien woody here on the
show how are you Damien which I'm doing
well are you doing I'm fine I think it's
a perfect timing I think did you send a
text to him at the same time really
impressive what do you think what do you
make of Kevin Cole Bert's comments
yesterday Damien you know I found it odd
you know because it was just unsolicited
um
just hidden knowing what you had said
prior to me coming on it why do you have
to announce that your quarterback who's
a you know first of all the Hall of
Famer and we have all the accolades to
you know to back it up that he's the
unquestioned leader of the team it just
it just seemed really odd to me and
thing that really struck me about the
whole conversation was the whole 52 kids
thing and as a former player that struck
a nerve with me because I'm thinking
there's marquise palace II think of
himself as a little kid who's 29 years
old 17 to me 7 Pro Bowls two first-team
all-pro I don't think he's uh I don't
think he's a kid what about Alejandro
Villanueva who served our country you
know as an Army Ranger 30 years old
twice
you know two-time Pro Bowler so for a
general manager to come out there and I
understand I think that it was probably
probably bad it worded on his part and I
understand that he has to stick up for
you know Ben Roethlisberger after you
know what Antonio Brown said about him
having the owner mentality but when the
locker room is it's a careful situation
you have to strike a careful balance
when it comes to the locker room because
usually players always view the front
office's as the enemy quote-unquote and
for you to come out here and and back at
quarterback up to that point guys must
and Laughlin's start looking at will
they probably already have start looking
at Big Ben is like wait a minute are you
one of us or you wanted them I think
that to me even when lady on Bell moves
on and Antonio Brown event we all think
he will move
on it still doesn't remedy all the
problems that's been going on in that
locker room I I agree
Damien now obviously wins will help all
that and Ben is just he's he's as
terrific as they come in the NFL so you
can't dispute that my question for you
is is that do you think the answer is
players in the locker room asking Ben
how to get better as Kevin Kolbert
suggested well my thing is is it is it
up to Ben to critique guys on how to get
better that's what the coaches are there
for well but we don't question that when
if Rodgers says something right or Brede
or Brady might say something I mean we
don't question that but we do it Ben
well I think it's also kind of it's kind
of funny that you know Antonio Brown
comes out and says that Big Ben has this
owner mentality how many guys have run
to Big Ben's defense I haven't seen
anybody I haven't seen about it on
Twitter or any other type of social
media platform or television to really
come come to Big Ben's defense and all
this I found that I find it very
striking that we haven't heard from
anyone as a relates to this ad Big Ben
saga really makes you think doesn't it
yeah I mean what so what do you think it
all does mean is that that you've got a
general manager pounding the table that
is first-ballot hall-of-famer is not
only the unquestioned leader of the team
but has every right to question anybody
else and as a matter of fact players
should question him on how to get better
and nobody's out there saying that
themselves so what do you think it does
really mean Damian that there's a
problem in the steelers locker room for
real when tow does meatball in the 2019
season I think that I think there's
gonna have to be some some
behind-the-scenes talking going on I
know if I'm a player yeah last thing I
want is a it's another player in a
locker room listen all the accolades
that Big Ben we you know that you've
talked about first team you know first
ballot hall-of-famer
and and all the numbers and all that
guess what you put your pants on just
like I do all right
none that matters to me so it it doesn't
give you the right just because you're
big band doesn't give you the right of
go on radio whatever other platform you
have to rip me through the media it's
one thing if Mike Tomlin does that ok
that's fine that's my superior that's my
coach before a player to going to go on
radio soon like every week he does that
I think you know like I said I'm gonna
play a lot for a week that's something
that we would have to nip in the bud
this offseason because we can't we can't
run this whole saga back next season
where we have drama and all those type
of things going on that would have to be
nipped in the bud ACL I mean Kohlberg
gave him the green light to do whatever
he darn pleases I mean that's just I
just think that's a big that's it to me
that's a problem that's a problem you
got the gym enabling your quarterback to
do that again players looking at front
office they look at farmers as almost
the enemy and now the front office is
enabling the quarterback to just openly
rip your players ripping one ripping
teammates through the media I mean who
does that who what other organizations
allow these type of things to happen I
don't see this in New England I just it
to me it doesn't make any sense at all
Pittsburgh exists it's just a mess to me
mm-hmm
Damian what are you here on the Rich
Eisen show would you would you if you
were a general manager a coach or a fan
of a certain team would you acquire
Antonio Brown Damian would you say let's
go get him right now which I've thought
long and hard about this one no cuz I
come from two schools I come from the
New England way where you know it's all
about it went buying in but I also know
New England's an outlier know you like
everything that happens in New England
it's just not it doesn't happen around
the league and one thing I do know what
the Antonio Brown as much as we talk
about the headache and all the things
that he does for social media and the
outbursts you see on the sideline
there's only one guy NFL history this
has six straight seasons of a hundred
catches plus that's Antonio Brown
you don't think Antonio Brown can help
Aaron Rodgers take that Packers team to
another level in Division with Chicago
Bears this should be teams this should
be a lot of suitors out there for
Antonio Brown this guy's no one
questions his work ethic that's one you
can say a lot of things about Antonio
Brown you cannot question that man's
work out there that man wants to be
great if sometimes we need help
transcendent talented God that works his
tail off but yeah he's a pain that he's
a pain in the butt sometimes you gotta
weigh that and you gotta accept that in
order to in order to bring that
greatness into your locker room and on
the playing field because not every
player gonna be choirboys
but the packers in her spot you'd say
you'd take a shot at it cuz I guess what
12 could look at him and say you know
this is the way we do it here even if
they have a new head coach or San
Francisco might not be ready to win a
Super Bowl right now and you have to
understand - he wants guaranteed money
so it when he does put up the numbers
that we know he'll put up he's gonna
want some sort of guaranteed contract if
he already doesn't have it you know like
that's the sort of stuff that that also
has a problem with the locker room
certainly if he comes in and guys who've
been waiting to get paid watch him get
paid right Damian I mean that's an issue
- you got no way the same time you rich
not everyone is a Antonio Brown there's
a pecking order that's just the way the
NFL is a meritocracy okay not many guys
there's no one in the NFL that has the
numbers Antonia Brown has so be fair but
that's just what it is so you're waiting
to get paid yeah let's just say day me
what are you wait and get paid and and
the team has been putting it off Sam
we'll get to you will get to you we'll
get you and then acquire a guy who
walked out on his team in week 17 by all
accounts and we're gonna start paying
him much more than we thought we'd even
even get paid you would have a problem
that because you know it's a meritocracy
listen I yeah I don't have issue with it
but I understand the way the game is
played I understand the way the game is
played I understand the way the league
operates at the end of the day race is
all about winning
that's not
all people care about think about all
the things that people willing to put up
with just to win okay we got a cream
hunt you had him on videotape we got a
team that went out here and brought him
in because he's because they want to win
that's what it's all about in the
National Football League and that's why
I brought up Aaron Rodgers I brought
Green Bay and Aaron Rodgers and the
Green Bay Packers seemed like this team
- they do everything like they do
everything so so right mm-hmm they do
everything so right they don't really go
on free agent like that they want to be
home they want to draft homegrown talent
and and so on and so forth
well guess what the Chicago Bears are
here the Minnesota Vikings are here okay
you got you went from breath Falls to
Aaron Rodgers are you gonna keep wasting
that man's Talent okay he's getting
older than little bit he's getting beat
up more what better way to infuse or
Aaron Rodgers then to put a be next to
Davante Adams that'll be something about
that and Aaron Jones do you have first
round picks
what first round is gonna give you the
production of Antonio Brown Danny make
arrests you brought up the San Francisco
49ers well guess what how many more
years of rebuilding that you can do in
San Francisco you had the Rams in the
division you had two Seahawks in the
division you paid Jimmy Garoppolo a ton
of money at some point you got to
realize that contract
Damian loved the chat love your work
let's do this again real soon looking
forward to it thanks again
that's Damien woody you check him out on
ESPN the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience